from sumatran rat monkeys and drug
addled puppets to billionaire
peter jackson famed lord of the rings
director and co-founder of special
effects studio weda digital is worth an
estimated 1.5 billion dollars
jackson was born in 1961 in new zealand
or as you might know it middle-earth
both of his parents were english
immigrants and settled in pekurua bay
right outside of wellington
peter was their first and only child
one of their neighbors happened to work
at kodak and gifted the jacksons with
their first super 8 camera
it wasn't long before peter's natural
instincts kicked in and soon enough he
was directing a war movie granted peter
was eight years old and the trenches
were holes in his mother's garden but it
was a start
when he was nine he watched king kong
for the very first time and it blew his
mind
after watching it he experimented with
stop-motion special effects making
little dinosaurs out of putty
little did he know what life would bring
as a teenager he got a job at the local
newspaper but was still experimenting in
film and special effects
further perfecting his craft
he created a realistic gorilla costume
to play a prank on his manager who then
wrote an article all about it
soon jackson was getting calls to help
out making props for real movies and
expanding his network and his resume
jackson continued in the movie industry
and co-founded weda digital in 1993 to
create visual effects for his film
heavenly creatures which featured kate
winslet in her film debut
the shop went on to create effects for
contact as well as jackson's own the
frighteners
and while peter jackson was consistently
working it wasn't until the lord of the
rings that jackson and wedda became
renowned for their special effects the
trilogy won 17 oscars including best
picture and best director honors and the
total gross worldwide box office revenue
was nearly 3 billion
jackson made 10 million dollars up front
for each of the three lord of the rings
films with at least another 10 of
profits earned from each film's box
office receipts
there's room for a little more
he went on to direct the 2005 remake of
king kong
you know the movie that set his
childhood dreams into motion
and his days in a gorilla costume were
put to good use wetta ended up creating
the special effects for the film
and just when it felt like jackson
couldn't top all that he went on to make
the follow-up trio of hobbit movies
which brought in another three billion
dollars worldwide at the box office
all in all the lord of the rings trio
plus the late hobbit films generated
more than six billion dollars in
worldwide box office receipts
about 1.1 billion dollars came from home
video sales with merchandise adding
another estimated 2 billion dollars
jackson got a piece of it all making him
one of the most profitable directors in
movie making history
and wedded digital became known as a
bonafide hollywood powerhouse churning
out effects for hits like avatar the
jungle book and chongqi and the legend
of the ten rings
the technology that was used to bring
tolkien's universe to life was just
acquired for 1.6 billion dollars by
unity software the video game maker
behind hit games like pokemon go and
among us
the sale sent jackson to billionaire
status
the deal means jackson and his life
partner friend walsh will collect an
estimated 600 million dollars in cash
and 375 million dollars in sock
but he doesn't seem to care too much
about all that when we interviewed him
in 2004 he said in america wealth is
kind of a thing of pride here it's the
opposite
regardless of how he feels it's not too
bad for a filmmaker who got his start
with a movie about aliens who turned
humans into fast food
[Music]
you